Scientists in Switzerland are working on an
alternative to antibiotics - and the impact
this has on medicine could be enormous.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and we’ve
talked a lot over the past couple of years
about the overuse of antibiotics, and how
it’s been leading to new strains of antibiotic-resistant
bacteria.
According to the World Health Organization,
over 50,000 people in Europe and America alone
- die of drug-resistant bacteria every year.
But finally, there is good news on the horizon
- a team of scientists in Switzerland is currently
working on developing an alternative to antibiotics
- that can treat several bacterial infections
and eliminate new strains of antibiotic-resistant
bacteria.
The team has managed to engineer nanoparticles,
composed of liposomes - which are small fluid
sacs enclosed in a lipid bilayer.
Typically, these kinds of liposomes are used
to deliver medication into your body - but
here, they’ve been designed specifically
to attract bacterial toxins.
The nanoparticles composed of these liposomes
closely resemble the membrane of host cells
- meaning that once they’re injected in
your body, bacterial toxins will mistake them
as naturally occurring lipids and try to infect
them.
At that point, the nanoparticles will consume
those toxins, trap them inside, and neutralize
them - preventing the spread of toxins.
Without those toxins, the host bacteria will
basically be rendered defenseless - and once
that happens, your body’s natural immune
system will easily be able to eliminate them.
The team has already conducted successful
studies on mice, in which they’ve induced
septicemia - a fatal blood infection - by
injecting mice with various forms of Staphylococcus.
All of the untreated mice, died within 33
hours.
But those who were administered this new drug
within 10 hours of the initial infection - managed
to live.
Not only that, but they were protected against
pneumococcal pneumonia - which can occur as
a complication of septicemia.
Scientists warn that while this isn’t a
cure-all for every infection - since each
species of bacteria requires its own tailored
solution - they do believe it could eventually
be used to treat MRSA infections.
And they plan to make it freely available
worldwide, very soon.
What do you guys think about this?
Could you see this changing the way we think
about medicine?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
down below - and as always, thank you guys
for watching!